présente mais c'est le président laurent
et rapport là donc là aussi c'est une
une demande de rapport sur un sujet qui
fait l'actualité ces c'est hors dernière
puisque faire la clarté sur
la question des fermetures de lits
d'hôpitaux malgré la pandémie
cent mille 700 lits d'hospitalisation
complète ont été fermés
selon une étude du ministère de la santé
mais on apprend de surcroît hier que les
fermetures de lits faute de personnel
serait beaucoup plus importante que ça
puisqu'on parle de 20% de lits fermés
pour ces raisons et dans l'interview
qu'a donnée le ministre de la santé
accompagnant ces révélations il dit il
conteste semble-t-il où ils demandent de
les vérifier les chiffres de cette étude
qui était conduite par
monsieur delfraissy donc pas n'importe
qui le président du conseil scientifique
et il répond dans cette interview
personne ne connaît exactement les
chiffres et ils demandent le soir même
le gouvernement de les vérifier
c'est pas une petite question la
question des fermetures de lits après la
pandémie donc là aussi nous voulons un
rapport qui disent clairement où nous en
sommes sur cette question et qu'on
arrête de balades et les gens et la
représentation nationale sur la réalité
des fermetures de lits et qu'on y voie
clair une fois pour toutes donc voilà
pourquoi nous demandons un rapport sur
cette question